Sonntagmorgen in torrijon der Erdos die
Stadt hat ein Fußballturnier organisiert
für 14 bis 15-jährige Mannschaften aus
Arbeitervierteln treten an doch das
Hauptthema findet am Rande des
Spielfeldes statt
hätte diese Aussagen nicht machen dürfen
vor allem weil er ist wer ist
repräsentiert wen er repräsentiert
dieser Herr muss zurücktreten denn er
vertritt die Marke Spanien und er kann
er nicht hergehen und solche Sachen
machen die die ganze Welt gesehen
gemeint ist der Übergriff nach dem WM
Sieg der Frauenmannschaft verbanntschaft
Louis rubiales küsst Jennifer er muss
auf den Mund sie sagt gegen ihren Willen
ob ihr alles selbst klingt es seither
trotzig ab Konsequenzen zu ziehen ich
trete nicht zurück ich trete nicht
zurück ich trete nicht zurück
rubiales stellt sich als Opfer eines wie
er sagt falschen Feminismus da einige
Männer wieder Nationaltrainer
applaudieren
im Grunde ist der ein Mann der erstaunt
darüber ist dass ein solches Verhalten
ihn seinen Job kosten könnte er ist ein
Mann der sich wundert dass er plötzlich
nicht mehr die Legitimität hat so etwas
zu tun
und da spricht dafür dass sich dieser
matschismus einer starken Kraft
gegenübersieht die ihm ein Ende setzen
will
landauf Land ab Ehren Gemeinden wie hier
auf Gran Canaria ihre Weltmeisterinnen
und die wären sich gegen den matchismus
an der verbandspitze
ich verurteile den Applaus den wir im
Fernsehen sahen ich unterstütze Jennifer
er muss so wir alle stehen bis zum Ende
hinter ihr finanz
von den Nationalspielerinnen bis zu den
Profis der Männer zeigen Spaniens
Fußballer seit hier ihre Solidarität wir
sind alle Jennifer
probiales wird vom Weltfußball Verband
suspendiert doch die Diskussion schwappt
über die Stadien hinaus die
Arbeitsministerin eine linke trifft sich
demonstrativ mit der Spielerinnen
Gewerkschaft spaniens Regierung vertritt
eine deutliche Position den applause wer
immer einer Verletzung von Rechten
applaudiert wer immer mutmaßlicher
sexueller Gewalt applaudiert denn das
ist nicht ein harmloser Kuss der sollte
nicht in seinem Amt bleiben
die spanische Gesellschaft ist eine
zutiefst feministische die ganz vorne
steht bei der Gleichberechtigung
nach dem Fall eine Aufsehen erregenden
Massen Vergewaltigung 2016 bei der die
Täter kaum belangt wurden reagierten
Gesellschaft und Politik empört die
Regierung verschärfte Gesetze und
stärkte die Rechte von Frauen Feminismus
ist seit hier in Spanien breit verankert
ich denke dass Spanien weit entfernt von
einem Feminismus ist der nur
institutionell und akademisch geblieben
ist es gab eine autonome starke und
mächtige feministische Bewegung die in
der Lage war sich zu artikulieren sich
zu mobilisieren und in die Gesellschaft
einzudringen
die Folgen dieser Mobilisierung sieht
man bei Anlässen wie kürzlich in der
Gemeinde Chipiona ein Mann hatte seine
Frau umgebracht was anderswo als
häusliche Gewalt verharmlost wird gilt
hier als feminizit der im Ort zu einer
offiziellen Schweigeminute führt und zu
einem Versprechen
ich verspreche Ihnen im Namen des
gesamten Stadtrats und der Bevölkerung
von Chip Jona dass wir von Seiten des
Rathauses und der
gleichstellungsdelegation unserer Arbeit
fortsetzen und keinen Schritt
zurückgehen werden damit dies der letzte
Fall ist in dem eine Frau angegriffen
wird
[Musik]
wie viel sich in Spanien in Sachen
Feminismus getan hat zeigt sich
besonders dort wo in der Vergangenheit
Männer dominierten na was der Reihe ist
einer von vielen ländlichen Orten in
denen heute Jungen und Mädchen den
Stierkampf erlernen
früher war das schon komisch wenn ein
Mädchen stierkämpferin sein wollte oder
wenn sie in die Arena kam aber jetzt
glaube ich ehrlich gesagt dass ich das
ändert es ändert sich
sie sind genauso mutig ich glaube das
ist was für Männer und auch für Frauen
nicht nur für Männer
es ist wie beim Fußball entscheidend ist
auf dem Platz und Frauen haben sich auch
in dieser Arena viel Respekt
erworben-festival war schon immer ein
Spiegelbild der Gesellschaft
lebten und diese sich auch in der
Stierkampf-Arena ausgebreitet hatte
im Laufe der Zeit hat sich die
Gesellschaft verändert so wie beim
Stierkampf und in anderen Berufen
so erklärt sich am Ende beides der stolz
auf den Weltmeistertitel der auch als
Folge der gesellschaftlichen
Gleichberechtigung gesehen wird und die
Reaktion der spanischen Regierung im
Fall robes sie hat das oberste
Sportgericht des Landes angerufen um ihn
aus dem Amt zu drängen selbst die
konservative Opposition widerspricht
nicht denn probier alles Mal tschüss im
modernen Spanien nur noch als vielgriff